who do you want to see right we we have
will have 30 or 40 probably great
candidates running for president 40
really 40 candidates yeah I mean you
know there's a lot of US senators who
are talking about a lot of Governors a
lot of people outside of politics I
think we're gonna have a big field and
you thought the GOP field was big in
2016 a 30 or 40 people Wow well just
look at these recent developments as
Democrats continue to embrace
Beatlemania it goes unabated old Joe
Biden is rearing to say that hey wait a
minute
Amtrak minute here ok I think I'm the
most qualified person in the country to
be President he said well there's a new
twist to all of this tonight just hours
ago it was reported that baitoey Rourke
secretly met with President Obama who
was said to be very excited about his
potential candidacy so how bruising will
a Biden bado Democrat primary be throw
in another 28 people or so here to
debate Corey Lewandowski former Trump
2016 campaign manager and Juan Williams
Fox News political analyst co-hosted a
5-1 Obama's old staff seems to be you
know prepping an instant kind of plug
and play for the bait o presidential
campaign your thoughts well not quite I
mean Rahm Emanuel the mayor of Chicago
has said you know you got to win
something and he thinks the idea that
bait or work did not win versus Ted Cruz
in Texas means that he shouldn't be a
contender here he's got to prove that he
can be a winner but I see lots of Obama
people to your point
Laura saying and Obama people saying hey
you know what we haven't seen excitement
this kind of charisma this kind of young
people attracted to a candidate since
2008 and that's Barack Obama and by the
way in Iowa they've just done a survey
and it came back that most of Iowa
Democrats say they'd like to see a young
energetic new face on the scene and I
don't think there's anyone who fits that
bill better than o'roarke yeah but of
course there's old Vice President Corey
a Joe Biden clear
doesn't feeling a love hear me he is
pretty experienced okay it was vice
president for eight years and this in
been Robert Francis you know does the
shirtsleeve thing kind of like Obama
used to do is to jump on stage his
shirtsleeves its young and energetic and
loved by you know loved by a lot of
Democrats I mean I've never seen
anything like it someone who's never won
big position looks like the Mojo and the
energy is moving to him never say
anything like it well this reminds me of
Robert DeNiro Raging Bull when he says I
could have been a contender I could have
been somebody but you gotta win first is
when it comes down to next thing you
know you got to tell me the ticket is
gonna be two failed candidates bata well
Roark and Andrew Gilliam from Florida
going to combine to be two losers who
are going to run when we've got a quote
experienced candidate like Joe Biden
that means old to the average person
experience means old the frontrunner for
the Democratic nomination are both in
their mid 70s and then we've got
Elizabeth Warren and Camilla Harris and
all these others who can't get out of
their own way who want to run to the far
left and the Democrats are going to
nominate a very liberal progressive who
don't troubles gonna walk all over well
one you know there was another guy who
ran and won and hadn't run and won
anything a Donald Trump I would call
office and he won the presidency yeah
and also hey Cory but I mean Donald
Trump's up in his 70s so Joe Biden's
highly experienced I think when Joe
Biden says he's the most qualified it
reminds me you know George HW Bush very
qualified lots of experience you can't
argue with Joe Biden's many years in the
Senate and also as the head of the
judiciary they don't want Biden they
don't want bite they won't get you know
lose the number one you know we have it
Biden's to on the Harvard Harris poll
put it up its Biden 25 Bernie Sanders 15
Hillary Clinton's 13 bit overworked nine
percent I don't think that any of that
means anything right now cuz I'm telling
you although although Obama is meeting
with he's met with Bernie Sanders he's
met with Elizabeth Warren and Mitch
Landrieu speaking of people who like to
pull down statues in the middle of the
night or at least counting
that mitch landrieu so the Obama folks
and the president for mur president
himself they kind of running out of
patience for Trump Cory come on it's
done let me see it let me show you how
it's done in bado is kind of the he's
kind of the as he's described by was it
the New York Times The Washington Post
says the white Obama liking him is that
way look look the book that Obama has
seen all of his signature policies
reversed under this president he's seen
the economy explode he's seen the
magician that he claimed didn't exist
which was Donald Trump bring jobs back
to our country he's seen this president
renegotiate bad trade deals and he wants
anybody who can challenge him
the problem is look in the in the 2016
election we had the adult debates with
me other children's debate which was two
separate stages now with 30 candidates
we're going to have the geriatrics
debate the losers debate and everybody
else on the stage I mean it's amazing I
have 30 people you gotta be kidding me
all right guys I want to get your
thoughts at something else so because
tonight or mourning the passing of a
presidential campaign that never got off
the ground Michael avenatti announcing
on Twitter that he will not run in 2020
could we possibly get the porn star
attorney to change his mind and give Joe
and fado and Kamala run for their money
one I think only if we want to tickle
you and Cory because you guys would have
a field day talking about him and stormy
Dan isn't all that I think stormy
remains on the scene is kryptonite to
trump but I think you guys as political
people would think how ridiculous now I
must say he does reveal an instinct on
the Democratic part which is they want
someone who would go toe to toe slugging
it out with the heavyweight champ Trump
right and so avenatti says that's what
he'll do these other people he says you
know they're wimps they're going to get
run over by the big heavyweight Donald
Trump but I think you're gonna find it
that the Democrats have a big appetite
for someone who's a fighter but what you
know to me avenatti has just too many
deficits too many flaws going in he's
too much of a target for you guys yeah
well he talked about you need a fighter
in 2020 and yeah we get that
you also need someone who comes with
some level I think of gravitas and
experience I mean who knows where we'll
be in two years in the economy certainly
help the economy's doing well in two
years but you're gonna go up against
someone who's been through you know the
meat grinder of politics for the last
you know previous six years and that's
not easy I don't care if you're young
and energetic and good-looking you're
from Texas and you have a cool name that
doesn't mean you have the political
talent of Barack Obama he had an
enormous raw political talent Obama did
and we'll see about whether bado does
quarry real quick
close it out well and I agree with one I
don't think anybody whose nickname is
creepy porn lawyer had a real chance of
being the Democratic nominee I could be
wrong but I don't think it's a great
nickname to get into politics with
especially guys been thrown out for not
paying his bills is all these liens
against them I think creepy porn lawyer
had no real chance anyways alright guys
thanks so much